And our second question comes from Hardy Martinez.
He wants to know if the rules and format for regular expression
that we're learning now--if they extend to other languages beyond Python,
or if they are Python specific.
In general, they use almost all the same notation,
and that's partly because down underneath all the APIs that you see,
all the functions that you are calling,
they're using almost the same code.
It's based on some--someone wrote it way back, and it seemed to work well,
so people reuse it.
There are some differences, depending on
the language you're using and the library you're using,
and that's just something you look up in the documentation.
Python, for example, has a lot of documentation on what the symbols mean and whatnot.
Sometimes they'll vary, especially when you're getting to
the more obscure syntax features of regular expressions,
which we don't cover in that class.
Pretty much everything we talk about here is going to be the same throughout.
Okay, so students that learn this will not be behind
when they try to implement regular expressions?
Yeah, and what matters is you know what the tools are.
The specific character that means something,
it doesn't make that much of a difference.